l'échelle mondiale le cren a déjà reçu
plus de 64 milliards d'euros provenant
de 38 pays la plupart étant des
occidentaux parmi les principaux
contributeurs figurent loin en tête les
états unis avec 54 milliards d'euros et
l'aide américaine cible principalement
des objectifs militaires viennent
ensuite le soutien à l'économie du pays
et aux besoins humanitaires
l'autre principal contributeur l'union
européenne avec en tête la france et
l'allemagne avec un peu plus de 2
milliards d'euros dettes chacun au total
l'europe a déjà versé près de 4
milliards d'euros à l'ukraine ce à quoi
devrait s'ajouter les 9 milliards
proposés par la commission européenne
de son côté le royaume uni reste lui
aussi un contributeur important avec
près de 5 milliards d'euros dead malgré
ces contribution conséquente celle-ci ne
permettront pas de reconstruire le pays
dans l'immédiat d'après bruxelles les
destructions causées par la guerre
serait déjà évalué à 480 milliards
d'euros